what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and it seems like for
the past few weeks the entire Internet
has been talking about simps and simple
I mean that's nothing new when it comes
to viral memes I remember when everyone
was losing it over pals effed for like a
month and then all Tran sting shaggy and
of course
gamer girl bathwater and as is usually
the case with memes that absolutely
explode online they tend to change and
evolve way beyond their original meaning
the actual definition of a simp is
someone who does their best to suck up
to a girl in the hopes of gaining her
affection even though they have no real
chance of actually winning her over
people have now expanded this definition
to refer to anything from gone from
Hunter hunter simple for his dad to
Luffy simple for meat to goku simple for
a good fight but i am interested in the
original definition of simp and in this
video i will explain why simple for
anime girls instead of quote unquote
real 3d girls is the morally superior
form of simple simple for 3d girls might
make you the subject of ridicule and
mockery but simple for anime girls makes
you a man of culture as long as you simp
for the right to anime girls and not
someone like Sakura or Kira toes cousin
or Megumi
if you are interested in the deep
philosophy of simple for top-tier anime
waifu's definitely leave a like on this
video and subscribe for more cultured
content the first anime girl that I want
to talk about here is the rabbit hero
miracle from my hero academia if you've
seen any of my videos that mention me to
call you know that I'm a huge simp for
this amazing 2d woman not only is she
stunningly beautiful and incredibly
strong but her courage and badass
attitude make her a really likable and
motivational character I've always liked
that one line from spike Spiegel I love
the kind of woman that can kick my ass
and miracle can definitely kick my ass
all of our asses but if she does kick
your ass it's only because you deserved
it so take it like a man
you might have heard the saying thick
thighs save lives but what if I told you
that miracle literally murdered a
villain by placing her legs around his
head and then using her thighs to snap
his head right off
MiraCosta Kai's and lives and that's
okay because miracle is so committed to
the fight for justice that she's willing
to put her own life on the line and rush
into dangerous situations at a moment's
notice she lives life to the fullest
with no regrets and since she knows that
we all got to die sometime miracle would
rather die fighting for what's right
then live a thousand years as someone
who runs away from challenges and gives
in to fear even though she was
introduced fairly late in the boku no
hero story miracle has quickly become
one of my absolute favorite characters
easily top five maybe even top three you
can definitely call me a miracle fanboy
Stan and yes even a simp I spend a lot
of time talking about how stunning an
awesome miracle is in my videos and on
Twitter and at family gatherings and
then they make me go up to my room and
stuff but no matter how much I praise
miracle and suck up to her she will
never notice me I will never get any of
that bunny love because miracle is an
anime girl she's fictional 2d not real
and this my fellow Eve's is the loophole
this is our license to simp without any
social repercussions I mean we can't
possibly donate money to miracles
patreon in the hopes of getting her
attention we can't possibly be called
out for sucking up to her in the hopes
of getting laid since she isn't real and
we would never turn on miracle like the
3d simps did on the ok boomergirl
because hey we've already made our peace
with the fact that we will never date
her and that is what makes simple for
anime girls morally superior to simple
for 3d girls we the weeps imps are the
truly pure truly selfless
type of simp we have to accept from the
get-go that we will never be graced with
the love of our anime
and yet we choose to get up everyday and
simp
anyway we simp expecting nothing
whatsoever
in return we simp simply for the love of
the game
so yes the act of simple for anime girls
is morally and philosophically superior
to simple for 3d girls but then the big
question is which anime girls are worth
simple if you are a true simp of culture
a sophisticated connoisseur of the
top-tier
anime waifu then you will not simp over
just any anime girl it is not enough for
the girl to be extremely hot because hot
anime girls are a dime a dozen it is not
enough for a girl to just be quirky in
some way because again quirky anime
girls are extremely common I think I've
already established why an anime girl
like miracle despite being a recently
introduced side character deserves to be
the object of our collective simple
she's hot she's brave she's a badass and
she lives life to the fullest always
faithful to her own ideals even if they
cost her her life and yes she can
definitely kick your ass but thankfully
miracle only applies to smack down to
those who deserve it another anime girl
from an ongoing Shonen that is
absolutely worth the simp is my girl
metal onna from black clover she is
another character who is fierce badass
intimidating and extremely hot in more
ways than one she was also introduced
relatively late in the story and her
on-screen time has been fairly limited
and yet she has left such an impact that
she quickly climbed the popularity poll
rankings until she was in the top 5 in
both the Japanese popularity poll and
the VIS popularity poll clearly black
clover fans are men of culture who
understand the true art of the synth
meadow leona is a member of the royal
house Vermillion but she cares so little
about societal rules and expectations
that she decides to live in the
wilderness for most of the year hunting
wild animals for food and probably just
walking around the woods completely
naked and free unlike other Royals who
stay in
side the capital attend fancy balls and
jockey for political power
Mottola wanna doesn't care one bit about
your background bloodline or social
status metaluna respects one thing above
all others and that is strength of
character if you are strong determined
and courageous you will earn Medellin's
respect if you are shady dishonorable
and weak-minded you will never get her
to respect you no matter how noble your
blood might be and how many royal deeds
and titles your family might hold at
first
Madalena wants nothing to do with social
hierarchies and she prefers to live free
according to her own rules it is only
after her younger brother is gravely
injured by villains that she takes his
place as the captain of one of the magic
knight squads in order to make the
people who entered her brother pay for
their crimes and as you might expect
those people do eventually face the
consequences of messing with the family
of the uncrowned undefeated lioness
medal Ilona Vermillion medal Ilona is
Unchained by social norms unburdened by
social expectations and supremely
confident in herself and in her faith in
others she also has the incredible
ability to inspire other people to
surpass their limits and achieve things
that they never thought was possible she
can motivate even complete strangers to
overcome impossible odds and become the
best versions of themselves and this is
no small part due to the fact that you'd
probably rather die than have to face
the fierce and intimidating medal Ilona
if you give up and quit whether it's
training in the wilderness whether it's
taking on five enemies at once or
whether it's inspiring everyone around
her to be the best they can be
medal ona is an absolute anime queen and
she certainly deserves to be symptom IL
freh spective we've some lesser men
might be too intimidated by women like
meadow Leona and they might simp more
mild-mannered and soft-spoken wife was
instead like or charcoal or mimosa but a
true simp of culture knows that only the
fierce women like meadow Leona and
miracle are top tier and
a wife who's there are many other anime
girls that I could include in this list
Lisa Lisa from JoJo's Valletta from Code
Geass yo Cole from Gurren Lagann
although Yoko's got that kiss of death
thing going on so you really got to be
careful then there's kyoka from energy
kyoka and if you don't know who that is
then you really have to up your levels
of culture and finally of course there's
revi from Black Lagoon even I'm not sure
if I'd be man enough to handle Revie but
if you've got what it takes then simp on
my brother simp on please share this
video as prove that simple for anime
girls is morally superior to simple for
3d girls and please let me know down in
the comments which anime girls you
believe are worthy of being simp this
video gets 69 thousand likes I will make
a second video talking about more anime
girls that deserve to be sympton your
suggestions
well actually I've never had a single
video on this channel hit 69 thousand
likes so I'll settle for 6.9 thousand
likes okay if you're new to the channel
or you just haven't subscribed yet
please consider subscribing and hitting
that Bell to turn on all notifications
you can also hit me up on Twitter and/or
Instagram at anime out for shout out to
act cute sexy robots on Twitter for
letting me use their awesome fan art of
miracle on the thumbnail to this video I
want to give a big thank you to all of
our anime uproar patrons for making
videos like this one possible special
thank you to baby ray and a friend a
disciples of Lord Twigg o himself and I
can't forget all our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including in grata alone
Adam the world stealers the school bus
Tyson quit Ino acquired respect Pat a
heffa Jonathan king deci d and brandon
Ovilus finally big thank you to all of
our pro hero tier patrons including the
one and only Gilgamesh nothing but a fan
at Jason Wilson King's eldress Anatole
Cassatt's key on he'll crucify
Sparky 65 of Rohan Kapoor cricket xB Ted
no Ted Salter Joe Stanton very Gucci
Elisha actor animal as 69 jessica calif
on he no kami and water
Bonnie parks Zoe art 12 rasu Endora
Emperor otaku JCCC waka the coach and
Tendo if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value for you
please consider supporting us on patreon
even a single dollar gives you access to
our patron exclusive discord and your
name will appear in our videos along
with these amazing people as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see a space cowboys
[Music]